I'd like to invite you and welcome you
to the understanding anger 2.0 monthly
Series in which I will be presenting
about And discussing and answering
questions and comments about all sorts
of text thinkers topics that have to do
with this emotion this complex emotion
of anger and philosophical and literary
theological and other texts as well
understanding anger was a series that I
did back in Kingston New York at a local
library understanding 2.0 is one that
I'm doing for the entire internet
anybody who wants to show up can pop in
and hear me talk and a hopefully
well-researched way about the text
thinker topics for that month and get
the opportunity to ask questions through
live chat make some comments engage
about all of this sort of stuff so we've
got a lot of great sessions coming up I
hope that you can make some of them
maybe learn something in the process
anger is one of the most complex of the
human emotions and is so worth studying
and there's so many thinkers that we can
learn from in this process so I hope
that you'll join me and join in on
understanding anger 2.0